e
are
you
e
okay we'll open the work session we're
going to actually skip over 1589 we're
waiting for an amendment on that um we
will go next to the collection of um 318
1 005 and 252 and I believe
representative Maguire has an amendment
which you should all have in front of
you
1375 yeah thank you Mr chairman so this
is just a piece right our our the plan
that I I did with uh Mr Hoffman was to
combine all three of these bills
105 318
252 into a single comprehensive bill
which would be House Bill
318 and the reason we picked House Bill
318 as the final bill is that way
because it's a house bill it will have a
public Hearing in the Senate and
therefore um if there's more issues that
we somehow overlooked which I'm hoping
not um then you know they could be
resolved over there whereas if we picked
Senate Bill 252 then it would just
possibly have a committee of conference
so so my what I'm hoping we'll do is put
all the stuff all the changes we were
talking about into house bill 318 and
make House Bill 105 and Senate Bill 252
itl so the first one is this is the
house bill 105 piece so it's effectively
copied from House Bill
105 with the addition of training of
bail Commissioners which you find on
page two line
17 um that was copied from one of these
other bills and um the one difference
that will be in the final one you see on
line 18 it says the chief magistrate
that's going to be replaced with um the
judicial training
coordinator right so uh it it's the
judicial training coordinator that will
be doing all this training organizing
all the training and on if you look on
page one line 15 you'll see magistrates
and bail Commissioners were added to
that line which wasn't in House Bill 105
but other than that this is a mostly
House Bill
um you know with all the hours put back
and and all that stuff right so at the
top of page two you see all those all
those hours are back in
it are there questions for
representative
Maguire representative grassie
all Mr
chair I
just um are we going to stick with the
$50 even though there was some
discussion in your amendment I thought
to moving it to 60 because of what the
sen that's a second decision I
think um I can I mean I could talk about
it but we're not there
yet yeah the other this $60 amendment is
out there as well but this is what the
bill Commissioners shall be paid for
their training time
for each eight hour block of training I
believe and I was just looking back at
one5 as we received it and I don't there
was no money in there initially for the
training it just said that they were
going to require training
but is that as you recall it yeah it
sort of implied that we're adding a
position here right and so that's going
to cost something all that
so representative Maguire there's no
change we talked about a Bill Amend or
Amendment
1113 last week and that was the whole
discussion around shell and May and
there's nothing here to yeah so
essentially we we are going back to the
original house um language there um we
do have on line 12 under the direction
of the Chief
Justice right so the chief justice is
the the boss of this
person yeah
okay further questions uh saying none
representative cells are you okay moving
the amendment along or yes I'll move the
amendment is there a second
representative
Sweeny further discussion on the
amendment uh marford by representative
Maguire
1375 H I guess we can just again with
the understanding that page two line 18
will not be the chief magistrate it'll
be the judge the the um judicial
training Court yeah yeah
okay yes representative EV question so
so is the uh just getting back to the sh
and the May and the great concern that
the judicial branch had because you've
added I just want to put it out there on
the record because you have the language
in here under the direction of the chief
justice is the idea that that can give
some wiggle room to the training hour
requirement right okay so I just that's
what I thought so I just thought I would
say it here in the executive session so
that was clear from a constitutional
standpoint thank
you I'll give a little attitude Aon
we're in the middle of a vote
but I I apologize Mr chairman I
appreciate that I do see that there is
um at the direction of the chief justice
for the training coordinator but not for
the training
requirements um
so obviously the legislature can can
take the votes it wants to take but I
just want to be clear that my advice is
that this is an
unconstitutional so effectively here I
came down on the side of um chairman
Lynn in this
[Laughter]
argument yeah I mean again you know I
had originally gone along and and
proposed taking out all those hours
right but then we got pushed back from
members of the Judiciary Committee
chairman Lynn and and uh representative
Smith who said they like these hours in
there right so there they are any
further any further and we also heard I
mean just to be fair I mean we also
heard that these are these are lower
than they probably will want to do
anyways right
so are we okay with the show of
hands all those in favor of the OT
motion put their hand
up those
opposed unanimous oh one I'm sorry I
just no that's s right yeah no
problem okay H1 Amendment 8 to one on
the amendment
now okay now you have another amendment
right
representa I don't know what state
they're in so we we talked you know I I
spent time with with Mike um on Friday
creating you know asking for things
but all right thank
you okay so this is one I have haven't
proof read yet but
um this should be the comprehensive
thing so we should go through it section
by section I
guess okay all right before we go
through it representative Maguire I
think all the division members may have
received an email from chairman Roy on
the number of magistrates and I know
that representative Maguire would like
to comment on the letter and maybe even
read his letter yeah so what I would
like to do since he couldn't be here is
just I'll read you what he wrote and I
had responded to it and then he wrote
again so I'd like to read the whole
series if you don't mind okay so dear
this is from chairman Roy to to us and a
bunch of others uh dear division one
members I am aware that you will will be
conducting further work on the bail
bills today to to include further
discussion on
magistrates it was my hope to attend in
person but I have medical appointments
and so on um as my committee and house
duties require me to oh anyways this is
about appointments he's he's unable to
attend okay it is my understanding that
at the request of Representative Sweeney
you are contemplating cutting the number
of magistrates from 15 to 5 I've gone
over the number proposed and it will not
be sufficient to cover the policy or
achieve the broader goals not the least
of which being lowering the cost to our
counties I'm not sure what evidence you
relied on to arrive at the number five
but cutting from 15 to five in an effort
to lower the cost totally negates the
policy in which in and of itself is
designed to cut costs the magistrates
will save taxpayers money in the broader
impact of the policy despite
representatives scitec and ly's
protestations the magistrates are
necessary to make the system work
without holding someone longer than
necessary please keep in mind that the
cost to our counties of keeping these
people even two days longer than
necessary during our six months of
hearings we heard from the counties
regarding the medical expenses of any of
these
arrestes as the county is on the hook
for them and Medicare does not pay while
incarcerated I'm presuming he means
Medicaid but anyway it can be
enormous uh if an arrestd comes in with
no medication for a chronic condition
some of the medications cost thousands
just for a week's Supply when someone is
held for months pending trial the
medical cost can be astronomic iCal we
heard testimony that some inmates can
require medication that can run into
tens of thousands of dollars per month I
would call your attention to the duties
of the magistrates Beyond bail please
recall that we carefully studied the
increased burden on the already overly
burdened court
system uh the changes to the bail syst
system will cause as such the policy
provides broad duties for magistrates
that will free judges to handle other
matters to Al alleviate the bottleneck
currently we have people waiting
sometimes up to a year to have their
cases heard while they are waiting if
they are being held due to the changes
we are
making the cost for this goes on the
county governments the most expensive of
these being the medical costs I
referenced above the answer to the the
answer is to move these cases through
more
expeditiously when judges have more room
on their docket to conduct criminal
trials and motion hearings because they
are not spending entire days holding
arraignments and bail hearings the
system moves faster and people are
either released per a plea found not
guilty or sentenced to a state
facility please review the entire list
of their duties number one at the
discretion of the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court in consultation with the
Chief Justice of the superior court and
the administrative judge of the Circuit
Court magistrates may have the following
powers a to determine the release or
Detention of defendants on all days of
the week and at all times of day
pursuant to RSA 597 colon 2 B to conduct
arraignment hearings and issue decisions
on arraignments C to conduct bail
hearings and issue decisions on bail or
other decisions regarding the release or
Detention of persons pending trial
pursuant to RSA 597 col 2 D to issue
arrest warrants and process sees of
arrest e to issue search warrants F to
administer Oaths and affirmations and G
to perform such other acts and functions
as authorized by the Chief Justice of
the Supreme Court not inconsistent with
the New Hampshire con tion or any other
state and federal
law they then they there are their
responsibilities related to bail
Commissioners themselves they are
responsible for managing the bail
Commissioners within their counties that
includes recruitment training retention
and coverage as you can see these 15
people will not only handle the serious
bail cases on nights and weekends but
will also be a forced multiply for our
judges as I said a after original
arraignment it is not unusual for
criminal case to take six months to a
year to be resolved cases do not get
better during that time the prosecution
and defense often loses witnesses that
are key to provide proving either guilt
or
innocent um the defend defendant loses
any employment they may have had causing
the family to go on public assistance
and lose housing the ripple effect of
delayed case resolutions is Broad from
from the cost to our counties to the
Lost freedom of our citizens delay
Justice is not only Justice denied but
is far more expensive for our taxpayers
than the cost of these 15
employees there is also the electronic
monitoring aspect of the bail reform
package the magistrates also give the
court the ability to have them be the
contact person for violations of
monitoring conditions
with their ability to issue warrants if
a defendant is released on electronic
monitoring the court will likely
contract this monitoring service with a
private Company the company will need to
inform someone of the violations and
preferably that should be someone who
can issue a Judicial response in an
extremely timely manner as these are
people who have violated a protective
order I strenuously urge you to go no
lower than 10 with the number of
magistrates please avoid thinking of
them as just a more qualified bail
commissioner the magistrates are the
lynchpin of the entire bail reform
package and not an add-on they allow us
to hold dangerous people by giving them
a fair bail review while ensuring public
protection they create the ability for
judges to hear more cases move the
system along faster and more efficiently
if you must make a cut I implore your
implore you to make it Surgical and with
thoughts to the broader impact of the
entire policy and envisioned by the
criminal justice and Public Safety
Committee and supported by the house
okay so that was that one
so I
responded um first of all I said if he
couldn't be here perhaps he could send
someone else from his committee I don't
know do we have no we don't have a
person
hm okay so we have someone
okay if everyone would just hold off and
let represent McGuire read his anyways
so here's my response I said um the
simple fact is that the number of
arrests annually for the serious crimes
that you have said in this legislation
must be handled by magistrates and not
bail Commissioners is under
1,500 that's roughly 30 per week with
five magistrates that's six per week
each um we we asked how long does each
case take and we were told a half an
hour is a reasonable estimate even if it
is an hour that still leaves 34 hours a
week for each of the five
magistrates to help do other things to
help the courts we asked whether the
current number of
Judges with the current number of Judges
is the Court's backlog increasing or
decreasing it is
decreasing therefore all the extra
efforts by the magistrates to relieve
judges is just an improvement it is not
necessary okay um so here's his response
to that I would submit to you that to
characterize as
unnecessary is only accurate if you were
looking at the issue of bail of ser ious
offenders and ignoring the comprehensive
policy addressed in the package of
bills with defendants waiting 6 months
to a year for their cases to go to trial
our the cost to our County governments
is enormous our policy committee was not
limited to addressing the issue of bail
of serious offenses but instead took a
comprehensive look at the bail system
from arrest to trial which is the
duration of when someone is on bail when
when we discuss what is and what is not
necessary I would submit that we are
engaging in a policy
discussion the criminal justice and
Public Safety Committee spent six months
so this somewhat rep repetitive here um
investigating what is necessary and to
address the deficiencies we discovered
in our system you are of course free to
disagree with our results on the policy
but not what is and what is not
necessary to a affect the policy I
continue to maintain that a bare minimum
of 10 magistrates is necessary to affect
the holistic policy that our committee
put forward on this entire package of
bills even limiting to the maners of
bail as it becomes more difficult to
recruit and maintain sufficient bail
Commissioners their future in the
Judiciary is uncertain we have
previously discussed that there are
possible tax
implications related to their status as
well therefore it is important to
remember that while the crime limited to
only judge judges and magistrates is
around
1,400 the number of bailes made by bail
Commissioners is over 10,000 annually I
encourage you and the committee to
please consider the full bread of our
policy our committee established and the
Full House
endorsed okay that's
it all right so I guess I still think
the five is is reasonable it's it's a
step forward ward in the way he wants it
but on the other hand this this is not a
a budget year uh we gave the Judiciary
everything they wanted in the budget
they did not ask for
magistrates so if they felt that that um
the delays in the whole
system are were a serious problem they
could have asked for them they could
have asked for more judges they could
have you know so all that sort of stuff
and so we're we by adding five we're
reducing the backlog we're making
progress and so on and and we'll have
some experience when comes the next
budget as to whether it should be
increased or or not so I'm still happy
with what we have representative wer
followed by representative grassie thank
you Mr chair like any new program
there's a lot of loose ends who's going
to do the interviewing
how many will he be able to hire how
long will it take I don't think you
could find 15 people in a year with some
of the requirements you might it might
take six months to find five and then
how you going to work out the hours you
know well we expect you to be in the
office when you're not called on
weekends okay I spent 30 hours on the
weekend on this now how many hours you
expect me to work in the office uh and
it's easy on a busy weekend to spend the
almost the whole weekend doing that kind
of thing so it leaves leaves a lot of
loose ends uh we expect you to be in
court Monday wait a minute I was up till
3: in the morning on Sunday with some
idiots in three different courts now you
want me there at at 9:00 in the morning
on Monday give me a break um that's the
way it goes you can't be on call and
still have schedules throughout the week
that all has to be worked out and you
know and so until that's all done and
then we see If there really is a savings
then it will take a year or two to see
if what was the savings where were the
savings and all this stuff about all the
expense for the counties put them out on
electronic Monitor and go buy your own
drugs if you got $1,000 a week drugs I
mean we've run into that before in the
county and I think they let them go
rather spend that kind of money on drugs
and if if they needed that much
medication they probably weren't capable
of doing much else anyway but just the
thought that I'm looking at it as an
experimental thing you start off easy
see if there was any savings to see if
you did find the right people and then
go on from there and if you don't find
the right people and you can't find the
right people because the only one I
think that would be qualified for any of
this would be a retired judge and how
many of them want to work that job I
don't know you might have two a
three thanks representative
grassy thank you Mr chairman I had a
chance to talk to a few members of the
committee last week about this bill and
also and and the number of magistrates
in specific I also talked to my and and
they brought up the the issue of savings
at the county level and I had a chance
to talk to my County Administrator and
the administrator at our jail and they
reinforced that that there was a cost
involved here that they felt that this
is something that could help alleviate
cost at our County levels and you know
they they had a significant concern as
well as of as of us moving this to five
magistrates this was looked at as a
comprehensive approaches here I mean
we've been struggling with this for a
couple of years now and more than one se
you know two sessions three sessions
we've been we've been talking about bail
reform and ba reform has been an
important thing at the local level and I
think that what you have to take a look
at here is that the work that was done
by the policy committee and I read
chairman Roy's email this morning before
I came in I didn't see the respon want
but the thing is is it convinced me that
I think we need to have more than five
and you know and that's a concern that I
have that I think we're going to make
this work uh we need to have at least
one per County and I understand
Hillsboro has two courts so you need one
to have two so I think the minimum that
we need to have is 11 magistrates in
order to make this work if we only have
five this is not going to work we're
going to be back here next year and
we're going to be arguing this again the
under trouble is is once you put in five
we pass this and we get get five in
there it's going to be hard to fix that
and we should we should fix the problem
now so we can go back to our voters we
go back to our police Chiefs we can go
back to our counties and we can say we
fixed this and so Mr chairman if it's
not inappropriate I'd like to make a
motion I vote it on the prevailing side
on the bill on magistrates I'd like to
reconsider my vote on the uh on the
magistrate where we reduce it to
five is there a second to uh
representative grass's
motion to reconsider our vote and uh
just a reconsideration I won't take a
number but at least to reconsider a vote
I'll second that for
discussion representative Sweeny thank
you Mr
chairman I don't disagree but I do think
that if we set it at five there's
currently zero magistrates in the state
of New Hampshire if we were to set it at
five today and it becomes law in June of
or July of 202 24 and we can hire those
five magistrates and we come to the
budget next year and we realize that
five isn't enough it is pretty easy to
increase that number to S to 9 10 11 as
you proposed we would never if we
installed 11 and there wasn't enough
workload for those magistrates to do
we're never shrinking that back down to
five so I I still support five as the
starting point and acknowledging that it
is the starting point and that you know
while this legislation is going going to
do wonders at reforming the failed bail
reform from
2018 this is still going to be the
starting point of the fixes that will
take place and as the system grows as we
continue to implement the judicial
branches audit that they came to us in
the last budget with where we added some
judges we added the land use Court Judge
we're still expanding the judicial
branch over the next few years
magistrates are certainly part of that
expansion but they're not the total
answer towards it as well uh so I think
we're going to I I sticking to the
course of five from this committee uh
we'll see how the rest of the house uh
wants to respond to that and then the
other body on the other side of the wall
but five for me works so thank
you representative grass yeah I it it's
something that I think that you know
people are say we we we put the five in
and and we should be fine but the thing
is I think it's been expressed certainly
in in chairman Roy's emails that these
magistrates have a lot more to do than
Jess Bale and so and there's a lot of
backlog in the courts that we have I
know they're they're catching up but the
thing is it's still the process is far
too long we need to move the court
system along better than we have and
another thing that I found out is that
these um these bail Commissioners these
magistrates do not have to be lawyers or
previous judges many of they're looking
at the qualifications for these people
they're looking at people who may have
been police prosecutors in the past who
have a legal knowledge about the system
that can step into these jobs as well so
they don't feel that they're going to
have a problem filling these 15
positions at all so uh you know having
uh police prosecutors who or police
officers who work for departments local
departments uh and and do things at the
county level um you know as a town
planner I went before Superior Court
many of times representing the town when
an attorney wasn't necessary so but the
thing is is that these are people they
feel that they shouldn't have a problem
filling these positions and they are
people that they need in the system uh
and I think this is not only does a good
thing as far as bail is concerned but it
helps the entire Jud I system so I would
stand by my position asking for 11 is
what I would what I would ask for uh
because I think it is sorely needed in
our in our in our
state represent Griffin you have
something well I you know we went
through this whole thing last week and U
I'm impressed by representative
mcu's analyzing the time and what the uh
baill you know what the magistrates
would be doing and appears that like
five magistrates would be enough and
that's the decision we uh we we uh came
to there were several of us I think more
than one that didn't want the
magistrates at
all and U it's a compromise and
financially it's half the
cost and I think we got to start looking
at costs cuz I think revenues aren't
going to continue to to go up forever
and we are the finance committee and I
see no reason to change up prior
vote representative walner walner cells
anything else to add no representative
cim BRS yes thank you Mr chair yeah um
if it's true what you said uh
representative Grassley that uh they
don't need to be lawyers and they're
going to get that kind of a
salary that that I would just assume not
hire any magistrates and up the amount
of money we're paying the bail
Commissioners and hire more of them so
if that were the case but uh as it is I
would I would stick to the five
magistrates I believe that that's fair
and it gets us started in the right path
as for all the reasons everybody has
stated and I also think that given the
uh current uh level of un unemployment
which is very low I I I think you will
find it difficult to fill even those
five positions so I'm sticking with the
five representative
wer it's also a matter of how how much
assignment each one's going to have and
before we should talk about counties and
so on we should look at how many arrests
and try to drive figure out how many
arrests and divide these things that
they're their areas by the number of
arrests within a given area and that's
why when we came up with five it was
kind kind of like an executive Council
District so at least we know those areas
were evenly divided by population and
possibly by crimes committed so it it
would look at it would seem like a way
to to look at where the where the people
should be situated thank
you representative eil thank you very
much Mr chair I oppose the cut to five
last time and I continue to oppose it I
mean whether it's 10 or 11 um I again
have deep respect for the analysis that
was done over hours and days in weeks of
time by the policy committee and all the
stakeholders they came up with 15 I
recognize if you're going to cut you
have to cut somewhat so I could go with
10 I think we are potentially setting
them up for failure by understaffing the
program I think if you bring in the
magistrates they could be through
a a training program together we can't
forget that bail Commissioners are not
going to be able to weigh in on these 14
crimes that are set out in the in the
bill and um I think it's well worth the
money in my in my view so I'm going to
stick with my um vote to oppose the five
thank you very
much seeing no no further questions we
do have a motion on the floor to
reconsider our action of last
week that reduce the number of uh
magistrates from 15 to
5 and when the clerk is ready we'll call
a role on this
place I I I seconded so we could have
the
discussion
um well the the motion is basically to
rec consider the vote on um whether or
not um should change the bill as adopted
by the house from 15 magistrates to
five
um
Representative
no
noes
no no
yes
yes so now that we've moved by the
number
of five would you like to explain
anything more representative Maguire on
your amendment I was going through
making the comparisons that from the
last Amendment which was mine to draw
everybody in and didn't see any
significant changes other than you
brought the bail commissioner fee up to
60 from 50 right so maybe this would be
the best time to talk about um the 750
and the 9 yes the the monitoring stuff
um commissioner I guess uh you're ready
would like no no no I I meant the ankle
bracelets oh okay I thought you were
wanted to talk about the we we could do
so we could get the commissioner I get
the commissioner out of here good okay
so this is about um the bail
[Music]
um bail information system right so it's
it's a very small section I
think where is the money is on page
nine nine okay line well I'm sorry I'm
looking at
mine
yes right so it's a the top of page
nine so this was not drafted the way I
would like it to be
so
um so but I think he didn't do it
because we haven't taken a vote yet so
so maybe I'll make it like a motion
representative Maguire yeah we do have a
separate Amendment oh you have a
separate amendment to once we get this
could you hand that out now yes yeah why
don't we
doing it's the amendment um
right right so currently there's
[Music]
um uh 1 uh 736
million dollar here
allocated to
um uh some to the Department of Safety
some to the judicial branch to to do
this um bail information system a
okay yeah and so my proposal is to um
take it do have uh the department of
information Tech
technology um uh create such a system
and um allocate
$200,000 to um to go out and get a
vendor to to create it um anyways
so is that possible impossible what do
you think so commissioner if you could
identify yourself for the record and
those watching thanks sure good
afternoon Mr chair uh members of the
committee uh Dennis G the um
commissioner for the Department of
Information
Technology um so um I've I did a lot of
thinking about this over the weekend um
as well as communicating with the folks
that had you know done the the diligence
around the fiscal notes that or the
fiscal requirements that had been been
previously identified both by um the uh
court system as well as Department of
Safety um so what was is being proposed
in in in the original ask
was implementing functionality that's
inside the existing business processes
in the courts as well as in Departments
of safety and the entities in the
subdivi political subdivisions as well
um so the the and rep representative
Maguire was nice enough to send me kind
of an idea of what he was thinking of in
some level of detail so that I could
think about that as well those are two
very different
things um the what's conceived in the in
the amendment is a standalone system
that's not integrated to anything that
is a a separate business process um that
would be implemented uh separate and
additional business process that would
be implemented inside of a what I'm
hearing and understand as a very busy
system um would not be integrated under
the current constraints would not be
integrated to anything else
and and so you know my experience in
that kind of thing is when you you
always want to consider business process
first and then technology second and and
so um you know the the way the original
proposal was written it did consider the
existing business process um and making
sure that we were capturing information
inside the existing business processes
and and also um developing um the you
know the ability to query real time for
law enforcement officials as well as um
reporting um so I would say it's really
two different things um there's a
perception uh which you know I don't
again I don't know the business of of
the the court system um the uh judicial
branch but um they feel like it's just
not going to if we did something like
this the data just wouldn't get entered
it'd be an afterthought always and it
just wouldn't get entered and you know I
would tend to agree with that although
again I don't you know I couldn't say
I'm an expert on that business process
um if we were to do it this way as a
standalone date system I'm not sure
maybe I could do it for 200 I'm not sure
I you know I nothing cost 200 anymore
you know especially if I'm getting a
vendor involved the uh the inflation in
the tech sector has been well ahead of
the what we claim it is in the in the in
the consumer sector but um but you know
in in general when cons receiving of a
standalone database that somebody would
be entering and querying on it's not a
complex um system and I would you know
the one difference one major difference
if you were considering a standalone
system versus a comprehensive integrated
system is that this is criminal justice
information it needs to be uh sieges
compliant and we would need to make sure
our hosting venue which is tends to be
more expensive than a regular hosting
venue and we'd want to make sure that
anybody that was working on it um you
know could um pass the appropriate
background checks as part of the
procurement process I think I would
really have to go and do some homework
myself I'm a little dubious that 200,000
would be enough but I don't know I don't
you know more importantly I don't think
this approach is going to would work
very well for supporting your your legis
you know the legislative intent of this
bill um additionally um I don't don't
have any Authority or um for systems in
in the judicial branch so you know
that's having money appropriated to me
to do stuff on behalf of that you know a
big chunk of this would be a system that
would be working in that Branch so if
again if it was a standalone database
maybe it the money would be better
appropriated in in a um in the judicial
branch so so um that's my you know
that's what I came up with as I was
cogitating and losing a little sleep
over this over the weekend so happy to
answer any questions uh committee may
have are there any questions for
commissioner gou represent Maguire thank
you Mr chairman thank you for coming so
you said you you're not that familiar
with the processes of the I guess since
you don't do your department doesn't do
judicial related things right so so you
don't you can't probably answer whether
police officers currently have access to
any Judiciary Branch databases and so on
right that so this um to the extent that
I needed to be able to talk about this I
have an understanding because I asked
the questions but but so the spot system
that that was described in the there I
saw a letter that was sent I believe
some time ago to the a senate committee
on this that was prepared by the
department of safety so what they're
talking about so the two pieces of this
there's the the safety piece is the spot
system which is that system that they
make available to for law enforcement
officials to inquire about things and so
the monies that they had asked for would
make the bail information the new bail
information we're collecting and
maintaining available in real time
through the spot
system okay further so so those that
system is used by bail
Commissioners um the I I believe the
system that's used by bail Commissioners
is the system that's over on the uh
judicial side which is their Odyssey
system right now do those two systems
talk to each other or yes okay they talk
to each other today I see all right
which is one of the you so it's one of
the reasons why you know this this idea
of a standalone system is it's taking a
considerable step back from what they
are you know the existing business
processes there's already data
Integrations and you know I I sit in the
middle of that sometimes because if
there's a problem
sometimes it you know people may people
on the court side May perceive it as a
doit problem and you know the folks over
in safety May perceive it as a course
problem so sometimes we're figuring out
whose problem it is but but generally
speaking the system's reliable I I
seldom hear about problems and and you
know we have been incrementally
enhancing it for the entire almost nine
years I've been here okay let me ask one
more if you don't mind so you said that
um the system wouldn't NE necessarily
get used right and I I don't quite
understand that because um because that
would be using it would be a requirement
of the work that that employees do right
I mean office dispatchers would have to
when someone you know when Joe Smith is
stopped would have to consult the system
to know if Joe Smith is out on bail um
bail Commissioners when they bail
someone that would have would be
required to enter it into the system and
so on right so so why do you say it
wouldn't be
used
um what I heard from the folks in the
judicial branch is that since it's a
separate system that they would have to
use in addition to the system they're
already using and that since it won't be
you
know integrated into their systems that
they're currently
using adoption would be much more
difficult and and they're feeling like
it may be an afterthought a lot of times
because it's not in stream of the
existing business
process representative
grassy from what I understand from what
you said and being familiar with with
software systems in particularly ones
that don't talk to each other when they
when you want them to talk to each other
this has been a problem HHS has had for
years sometimes when people are put into
the system and people don't have access
I see a problem here and if am I
incorrect I mean if somebody is going
into this system that is being proposed
here for 200 $1,000 a standalone system
and somebody is working on the sponsor
they have to make they would have to
make sure to check both systems before
they could actually make an informed
decision on a case or someone that was
coming before
them I I I think that's correct um but I
you know the the the business process
for how a standal load system would get
implemented would have to be worked out
but I think that's probably true they'd
have to be using both systems and um so
in particular particular um for for you
know we like to use this term a single
paint of glass and generally you want to
have all the information in front of an
individual whether it's a law
enforcement you know or or a bail
commissioner or a judge all at the same
time so what you're looking at here is
the system that you're proposing or that
they're looking at funding here I don't
know if it's you're not proposing it but
the system that's being proposed is a
system that would integrate with the
spot system or whatever whatever
someone's using their desk it would be a
single system whether it be the spot
system or or the bail system whatever
and they would get the information so
you have spots on the department of
safety side you have Odyssey on the on
the um and this would be a third be
integrated with all that it would
leverage the existing
integration so the so the data would be
available on both sides thank
you in real time are there further
questions for the
commissioner so just so I have this
straight the amendment that we have in
front of us is looking for a sum of
$200,000 to develop a system that will
work to get make all these things come
together are you saying that that's not
enough I don't know I I'd have to do
some work on that but um to build a
standalone system and maintain it what
what the 200 doesn't comp uh uh have is
any ongoing um requirements to keep it
running and supported so it's a you
might be able to build it supporting it
there's no money there to to do that and
and so
again um you know you have you have
maintenance costs that that would be
required the the maintenance cost and
and uh for the for the system is
included in the original pricing by
safety and and the judicial branch as
well so I have one further question for
you the
$750,000 for the Department of Safety is
that a number they got from you as far
as they they worked with uh so the folks
on the business side in safety who run
spots worked with members of my team who
are embedded in Department of Safety to
generate that number and the vendor who
presently supports
it and that would require a contract
going out to bid through the GNC right
uh that would probably be a soul Source
Amendment with the incumbent because
it's it's going into the system we're
running today it wouldn't be yet another
system as as would be the case in the
judicial branch on the Odyssey system
they wouldn't it wouldn't be yet another
you know you Pro you potentially could
do another system but then you're
integrating you're creating two new
Integrations as well as the integration
that we have today which again is there
there's some technical comp there's
technical complexity every time you do
an
integration so the
9986000 for the judicial branch you had
no involvement with that whatsoever no I
didn't uh but when I when when I asked
the folks over there they had they had
um requested a quote I believe from
Tyler I think it's Tyler Technologies
who owns that the vendor of record and
so they requested a quote from them on
and I believe that's develop developing
the additional
functionality inside the um existing app
and supporting it for I think two years
or something like that represent McGuire
I think you had a question yes so if we
spend this 1.7 36 million what is the
ongoing
um maintenance cost annually
afterward I don't know the answer to
that but it I know that they I believe
each one of them built I can get that
information for the committee and follow
up quickly I'll get that from the folks
on both sides would you guess it's
hundreds of thousands or no um it's
probably going to be
within a small increment from what we're
already paying for maintenance of the
existing systems I don't think it's a a
huge left thank you all right Mr
chairman I'll I'll save time and
withdraw this
amendment all right Amendment 1179 is
being withdrawn by the
sponsor thank you very much you're very
helpful commissioner as
always so represent McGuire would you
like to continue with yes so so I think
the only other big thing in here is the
ankle bracelet aspect of it
um is that correct Mr
Hof I mean the rest of this is strictly
copied
from there are some changes I I have my
notes from when we submitted uh the I
trying to go through in the original
amendment that was offered to combine
and trying to line these things up and
because they don't line up it looked
like there were additional changes but
it's kind of difficult but I can go
through what we've submitted and I've
been checking to make sure that was
included yeah thanks yeah if you could
do that Mike that'd be great in
Amendment 1204 which was the lean
Amendment on
page 491 B3 on page
two the amendment would eliminate
paragraphs one and two because um they
would kind of be replaced with the
training Provisions that you've already
adopted in the other
Amendment and on page seven
which is the page with a lot of
bold it talks about the different kinds
of felony level offenses there's a
sentence in
there and the term substantial evidence
was used on line
12 and then again further
down
15 14
yes that that standard of yes
substantial evidence is replaced with
clear and convincing evidence yes so um
that's a good point may I speak to this
sure yeah so
um one of these bills created a new
standard of evidence
throughout existing law in this area
there's what's called clear and
convincing evidence um for um for these
decisions and and so one of these bills
added a new category called um
substantial evidence which is supposed
to be somewhere it's defined as being in
between um clear and convincing not not
as strong as clear and convincing but
not as weak as what was the other word
um preponderance preponderance of the
evidence or something like that and so I
spoke to um representative Lynn about
this detail and he recommended that we
do not create a new standard of evidence
because number one it's brand new it
doesn't exist anywhere else in law and
and so therefore there would have to be
training involved you know
considerable lots of different people
would have to try to learn what do you
mean by this and so on whereas today
everybody knows what clear and
convincing means they know what propound
of the evidence means and so on and so
he did not think that that there was any
benefit to doing that so we we took it
out um because
it's there would be costs involved and
and it and it was sort of an
inconsistency from one bill that dealt
with bail to another one so so we left
it as clear and convincing I
believe representative eil our
lawyer so uh basically this bill went
through the whole policy committee they
came up with this bill when you start
when you start dealing with standards of
evidence that is like policy in neon
lights and while I
respect representative Lynn a
conversation for him with him I don't
see how a finance committee can justify
changing the standard of evidence that's
used in these
cases in what we're doing I mean that's
a big
change and I it to me is scary
but representative
grassy Mike all I said is we don't want
to touch
that representative sede have anything
to add here representative
cells representative
wner all right well again I think this
was an issue that was was inconsistent
from one bill to the next right that's
why we have to make a decision
right I don't recall excuse me I don't
recall this particular thing substantial
evidence as being a problem that this is
the first time it's hit my
radar I if somebody else had an issue
they didn't bring it up with
me again
I think we need to be awful cautious
when we uh start moving into the policy
line of things chairman Roy's committee
did a lot of work on this months and
months and many meetings many public
hearings and I don't know why they use
substantial evidence but I bet there was
probably a good reason
why I yes sir if you could make it quick
um it very quick I'm very with this
I'm a uh my name is buz Sher I'm a
police commissioner in Portsmouth and uh
professor at the at UNH law school um
this issue of the substantial evidence
was really carefully negotiated over
several weeks during our process
uh and it it the change from clear and
convincing to substantial evidence was a
a very conscious one to deal with some
of the concerns from Prosecutor's
offices uh and
um easy for me to say
but it concerns me when we start pulling
policy threads because this this is a
comprehensive plan and you know in ways
that uh
uh I know him as Justice Lynn as Justice
Lynn doesn't know because he did not
appear in front of the committee uh this
makes a mess of things uh and you know
right now this bill has to support of
the police Chiefs Association the ACLU
of New Hampshire uh the prosecutors
Association a broad spectrum of uh
people across the political boundar it
really is the you can call it
nonpartisan or you can call it
bipartisan but the extent we start
pulling threads it unravels a lengthy
negotiation for this so I it it was very
conscious and we really uh it really
needs to stay representative wer please
thank you Professor can you give an
example like whether or not to bail
someone to see whether there is a risk
to safety of them eles or the
community what would be the difference
in that instance between substantial
evidence and clear and convincing
um sometimes you get in when you're
trying to decide whether there's clear
and convincing evidence of
dangerousness uh you get a piece of the
evidence or maybe all of the evidence is
ambiguous one people would interpret it
as clear as as dangerous clearly and
convincingly and other people wouldn't
uh by by lowering a
notch um it tries to help baill
Commissioners pay attention to who is
dangerous and that was uh better
attention uh to who is dangerous uh and
um it you know to be honest with you I
wasn't in support of it because you know
um but I I fully support it as a part of
this whole package what kind of criteria
are you looking at in this instance to
say well this is clear he's not
dangerous or this is clear he is
dangerous or well the the the the the
person making that decision be it a bail
commissioner ideally a magistrate to or
a uh a judge uh they can look at
whatever is put in front of them by the
prosecution and it can be uh it can be
evidence of verbal threats you know
particularly in like a domestic violence
circumstance it could be evidence of
verbal threats it can be a sequence of
uh violent crime convictions over the
years uh it can be the nature of the
particular crime that uh the person is
charged with uh it it it was intended
the original bail Reform Act which
included this clear and convincing
standard which which I authored for
Senator felt then Senator felus uh it
was intended to give the the judges as
much leeway as possible um to make sure
that people who were dangerous we're not
getting out on pale than representative
Maguire thank you Mr chairman so if we
add um this new standard of evidence is
it likely that that action alone will
generate a lot of court cases and
judicial decisions and so on since this
is a brand new standard of evidence
won't there be court cases that say does
this apply does this not apply and so on
I mean are we making a lot more work no
for the Judiciary no no there will be
there'll be one case that uh makes its
way through the system up to the New
Hampshire Supreme Court where they they
clarify if needed what it means uh one
of the reasons the you know it it would
have been a mistake just to put that new
new standard in there without
identifying that it's more than a
preponderance of the evidence you know
5149 and it's less than clear and
convincing uh we put a definition in
there there'll
be there'll be a period where one case
will get through the system uh but um I
think uh prosecutors and courts and
defense lawyers will sort this out
pretty quickly it's not it's not there's
not going to be any uh any significant
added
cost it's just part it will be part of
the judicial process of clarifying new
language all right thank you very much
can I ask one one more um are you aware
of any other states that use this um
language um I'm not aware of any other
states using this language uh in in
terms of bail I'm aware of other states
using clar convincing and I'm aware of
other states using a preponderance of
the evidence so uh yeah it was a it was
a new creation to satisfy a desire to
give judges a little more we leeway when
dealing with cases where there was
ambiguous evidence as to clear and
convincing and you know I will be
completely honest with you
representative McGuire I was not in
favor of this I was in favor of clear
and convincing but you know a Deal's a
deal and this was a part of a whole
package that um um all right I don't I
don't mind conceding this particular
point it's fine we can we can talk to
the senate about it and so on okay so
Mike can you figure out where that would
go to make this change yeah we would put
substantial evidence back in correct
yes
so we'll go back to the my amendment I
guess m yes okay on that
one all right so it would go yeah other
changes M on page
eight on line starting on line
26 there a sentence that said if a
person's case terminates without a
conviction for any offense the person
shall not be liable to pay the cost of
electronic monitoring that sentence is
removed I'm sorry Mike I you repeat that
it's on page eight y starting on line 26
26 says if a person's case terminates
without a conviction for any
offense the person shall not be liable
to pay the cost cost of electronic
monitoring right this was the point that
the counties objected to I believe right
that that um yeah you were supposed to
get together with the counties on yes
and that's what we did so so this is
um this does not refund um electronic
monitoring costs in the in the effect
that in the case where someone is later
found not to be guilty right so similar
to other fees and other things that
people pay when they're when they're
accused uh you know the bail
commissioner fee for one and other
things so so that's this because they
thought that the just the keeping track
of it and and being you know refunding
money is very difficult so that was the
point all right we all are we all good
with that
okay
next
Mike you know it's really too bad I know
it would be a lot of work but that OS
doesn't flag all these changes for
us yeah the the other major difference
if I might the the other major
difference in the monitoring area is
that the bills created it as a Judiciary
function and we've come to learn that
this is really more of a count County
function and so that's
why
um so that's that's how this has been
reorganized right and so
um and in particular one of one of
chairman Roy's points was that he wanted
the the magistrates to do this
monitoring and yet I've heard that it's
really sort of in appropriate
for uh judici Judiciary employees who
are you know giving out Justice to be
involved in the you know day-to-day kind
of kind of um uh monitoring of people on
bail and and that sort of thing it's
that's really more of a of a county or
law enforcement activity and so that's
why this is that was another sort of
substantial change here
here
I'm I'm going to need clarification on
that um because we had language to have
the counties operate their monitoring
programs um and I was unclear we got
some cost information and we kind of
extrapolated across the whole state now
was unclear if we were going to abandon
that effort and go back to the original
bill or how the language to um support
the County programs would be
worded um yeah so so I think you're I
would like we would like the counties to
do it I think so that means page8 lines
31 Etc need to be
changed because this still has it done
by the
courts
so representative Maguire based on my
notes you were going to get together
with the county and or count the
representative I see from the counties
is here are you in agreement with some
of these proposed changes not to put you
on the
spot
well okay yeah I asked for County
related but I guess it didn't happen
again I'll just remind the division we
really need to come with a conclusion
today although the chair of the full
committee gave us until 11:30 to fill in
any holes tomorrow but hopefully we can
get things done because Mike and Melissa
have to kind of button things up for
tomorrow morning a representative evil
does the judicial branch have any view
on this
change
thank you ma'am Aon krian general
councel for the judicial branch yes we
do uh we do not have any capability when
it comes to electronic monitoring we we
simply don't have a pre-trial division
in the courts in New Hampshire as other
states do um this would be rebuilding
with us some of the capabilities that
the county already has um so it it does
make sense to us to transfer the
responsibility from
us
are you C clear Mr
Hoffman I'm not sure uh how many
counties are
actually actually have electronic
monitoring programs
now or right so one of the big questions
in this area and it's just a difficulty
is whether or not the two smallest
counties or the three smallest counties
ought to be required to have this kind
of monitoring or not right and so um
because they're considerably smaller
they're they're very small by by
comparison so
um it appears that all that there are
very little or no fixed costs so what I
was concerned about is um coas County
and Sullivan County and to some extent
Carol County are are
about you know an eighth or a tenth of
the size of Hillsboro County right and
so and so if there's a fixed cost to
electronic
monitoring and it's a Per County kind of
fixed cost then it's it's ridiculous to
to impose that up on coas County for
example but um it appears from what I
can understand is that essentially all
of the costs are variable it's it's so
much per Monitor and and you know that's
it's a weekly rental type of thing um
assuming that's true then it is okay to
to you know impose this on All Counties
but I was considering at some point you
know putting in some kind of provision
you know all counties with greater than
50,000 residents or something like that
so that the really tiny counties would
be would be excluded um I you know I
could go either way with that
so all right
um anything else Mike and the changes
within
this represent a graph scene I I you
know I think that maybe something in
here because I know the state does
monitoring it through the state prison
and with people who are put out on bail
and I know that you know there are
counties that do this and maybe a
provision put in here that if County
isn't going to do it themselves that
they contract with somebody and that
could either be the state or another
County just a thought
sure on the page 11 of Representative
Maguire's
Amendment section starts with judicial
training
that language is the same as the
amendment that you adopted
earlier that was the house the 105
language with the
change um on the line
for educational requirements for bail
Commissioners on page
12 that now will read the judicial
training coordinator instead of the
chief
magistrate in the section on the bottom
of that that
page for
funding there are three Appropriations
one for five new M
magistrates one for uh the electronic
monitoring program within the branch
that of course will change depending on
the decision whether or not the counties
will operate
that um and those
paragraphs shall not
elapse and then we have the effective
dates at the
end so as far as the the monitoring goes
I think the language we had I had
discussed with the county was counties
were that um they could
charge um the uh the accused for the
monitoring and so therefore an
appropriation wasn't necessary again
because there doesn't seem to be any
fixed costs here it seems to be enely
variable and that seems to be in the
four counties that are that have this
feature this function that's what they
do so it it for them it wouldn't change
for the other six it would be just
adding this a similar program to what
the others
have representative Maguire you had an
earlier Amendment with a paragraph that
kind of spelled that out that each
County shall operate a monitoring
program and recover the costs through um
through a
charge I can take that
paragraph through a reasonable charge or
or something like that yes right and
where does that Amendment stand that was
uh presented last week I don't think
there was any action on it at this
point I'll see if I can find it make
copies
representative Roy had nothing to do no
AR no no arguments
here those in favor so Mike are we
putting an impossible task on you to try
to pull this all together for
tomorrow
so the issues with the Maguire Amendment
or not maybe issues is in the correct
word but that's
1204 I'm sorry that was my Amendment
the
1382 we should still talk the60 yeah I
was going to mention that though one of
the things I do support because I had a
standalone Amendment for bringing the
bail commissioner's fee up to 60 which
was in line with the Senate that
representative Maguire included in his
amendment I
saw did you did yeah you
did it's on
um I circled it wherever that was and I
was scanning through here Mr chair just
to be clear they're being paid 50 for
training and 60 for the work that are
you guys distinguishing okay yeah on
page nine of the Maguire Amendment uh
line 12 entitled to a fee of 60 versus
40 what they're getting now so you did
add
it okay or he did someone did maybe we
should talk and have a vote on that
one what do you think well you don't
like the 60
now yeah I'm
I I guess I'm sort somewhat reluctant
all right here's the
thing not only are we going 40 to 50 is
is a 25% increase okay 40 to 60 is a 50%
increase but not only are we doing that
we're we're guaranteeing that the money
will be paid the big problem with pay
these days is that some in some
districts they're only getting half the
pay that they're entitled to right so
you know that's another 50% increase for
some and for others it's not
but I don't know these are just
difficult numbers to no matter what the
number is it's probably too small for
the work I mean people aren't people
aren't doing this don't get rich to to
to make a living right I mean this is a
this is a stipend of some kind it's not
a you know it's it's primarily a
volunteer job right so I don't know I I
I personally if I had to pick a number I
would pick 50 um that is the house
position if you you know to for those of
you who think the house position is
sacn um and you know or you know I don't
know it's it's just a matter of judgment
I
guess thank you Mr Joe who put forth
that amendment that stand yes stand yeah
I yeah I had put it forward a week or
two ago well thank you I uh I agree with
it and I would support it
thanks we probably ought to vote on the
amendment that representative Maguire
put forward now there was an
understanding that we are not going to
take the language
or clear and convincing we're going to
go back to the original language there's
a 60
fee is in five magistrates are those are
major issues Mr Hoffman that this
amendment
changed yes and uh then the outstanding
issue would be the um County County uh
operation of electronic Monitor and
we'll find that Amendment
yep if you could please come to the mic
thanks and again your name name and
representing the
counties thank you Mr chair Kate hgan
from the New Hampshire Association of
counties I would just ask if you are
going to leave the electronic monitoring
with the counties you make the effective
date July 1st 2025 because we'll have to
go through budgeting processes and not
all counties are on a fiscal year some
are on a calendar year so I would want
to give them the opportunity because it
will require a contract um to get that
done before piece becomes effective if
it is a
shall and again that date again was July
1st 2025 because that'll give everybody
who's on a fiscal year enough time and
everyone who's on a calendar year all
set with that Mr
Hoffman thank you thank
you yeah how about show a hands on 50
versus 6 yeah welcome to to do that
representative Maguire is moving that we
stay at 50 versus 60 for the bail
commissioner fee and I'll second it for
discussion and there's been enough
discussion all those in favor of uh
keeping it at 50 versus
60 two and bringing it to
60 at
and it's probably 20
years it's been a long time since I was
a bail commissioner and that's what we
got uh 20 20 years ago so I had a bill
early earlier this year to raise the fee
of the Bureau of tax and land appeals
which hasn't changed in 40 years and the
committee rejected it as being too high
you also who
knows
Okay so we've got that little piece
taken care of so what we have before us
now is amendment
1382 uh which was offered by
representative Maguire I think we the
big issue perhaps it's a stale made on
support perhaps would be the five
magistrates versus 10 but I think we're
all in agreement on the other Factor s
May yeah
probably uh Griffin I
believe you seconded the or I seconded
for discussion for the $50 $60 for okay
but we're going to move on 138 if
there's a motion to move the Maguire
amendments with the understanding that
we've done some
modification and Mr hoffen will have
that for us tomorrow morning I hope and
it's moved by representative Maguire I
believe so you don't want to come back
at 11: and do that well we'll we'll have
a motion so he can move forward with it
oh okay yeah and it's seconded by
representative Sweeney so we all
clear well I as much as I'd like to
support um the Maguire Amendment I think
we've made some good progress as I have
a real hard time with the five for
magistrates if it was 10 I spent uh
several long phone conversations with
the chair Roy over the weekend we've
communicated uh through text messaging
and I respect the work that they have
done uh and when the chair tells me that
it unravels the plan it concerns me that
and I think he was willing to go down to
10 which I think was a sacrifice I know
it was for him but
U for that reason I can't support the
amendment is proposed with that one
issue as far as the number of
magistrates seeing no further questions
uh or comments if the clerk would please
call the
role um representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
cambrell yes represent chair Wier yes
clerk votes no Representative walner no
representative grass no represent chair
lean
no and again I want to make it very
clear I think there's a lot of support
for the work was done it's just an issue
on the magistrates is I think our
biggest
concern Mr chair I have that Amendment
with the paragraph in the county
language from last week all right yeah
we'll hand it out if this take a quick
look and if there's any
concerns do you have any more cannabis
amendments or are we all
good okay
thanks
better this will end up being
three House Bill
318 representative Maguire would you
like to describe your proposed changes
yeah so um I think all the beginning
stuff is is not uh it looks similar is
is the same
um right
so so this is the same language that you
looked at last week um prior to your
conversation right with Kate Horgan so I
provided a copy to Kate as
well
yeah so
um it's at line 22 is where County comes
in right so it's essentially the same
thing as was Judiciary except it now
says County right and
um the Indigent part is like I said
slightly changed uh line nine on page
two because the original Bill said if
someone was later found found innocent
they would get a re they would get a
refund and we we took that out this
allow and this allows them to to U
contract with a state agency or
government entity to provide it so they
could contract with another County to
provide that
service
[Music]
um yes line 24 right right line 24 y yes
right it's either or yes so exactly what
we what I said earlier yeah
anybody have a problem with uh
1251 just
to and this would be amendment to 318
now yes make 318 the vehicle
yep okay we'll just have a show of hands
on the Sweeney
move all right sh Miss Mike so good
thanks all right seeing that we've
gotten through uh
10005 318 252 will back go back up to
1589 I believe representa Maguire has an
amendment
yes yeah those will be am is about
certain
no indefinite
Poston
okay the
position where's
that oh this there's a coordin they won
accept are we okay representa Maguire
yeah so there's all
right yeah so this one
um so the main thing is we we discovered
that um the numbers we got from this was
that was that there was going to be like
27 cases a year and we decided and but
the but the National Guard was
recommending that we increase that to
40 um we decided to make this a uh
$5,000 a case type of thing rather than
because if you remember the original
bill it was A2 million doll a
year um just pay Straight payments to
counties and and so that seemed like way
Overkill so what this does is it changes
it to $5,000 a
case um and after any federal funds that
you know
um
microphones thank you do we still
require how many places there has to be
a court or do we just kind of leave it
up to what the demand
um I think that the
um so you've you've gotten rid of the uh
large counties the medium counties and
the small
counties right all that stuff so it's
strictly going to be at the end of the
year the county will send a bill and the
bill will say you know we had 10 cases
this year and so they'll get a $50,000
check
right so that's that's what it is um and
I think we put in a I put in a maximum
of 200,000 although I don't see
that I can uh walk through the changes
on this one if you'd
like I'm I'm sorry Mr Hoffman I can walk
through these changes yeah please
thanks so it amends the bill by changing
it from a grant program to a reimburse
ment
program provides that the
counties may receive an annual state
reimbursement on a perase
basis it as uh representative grassy
mentioned it takes out the
classification by size and the Caps
based on the size of the county so
everyone all the counties would be
eligible for $5,000 up to $5,000 per
case
um okay there there is a Max of $100,000
though which you know Li that's total
sum that's what we're appropriating is a
total sum so they wouldn't be able to
spend they wouldn't be able to receive
grants that's for hiring the coordinator
so and that has that will change
actually the appropriation um should be
$163,000 I had it wrong I've asked for a
correction on that 63,000 will cover the
half a Year's cost of the veterans core
coordinator then after that onetime
appropriation there's language for the
branch to include the cost in there um
by anal
budget yeah so the maximum appropriation
like
is the maximum would be in this $100,000
for half a year
so as as I had this drafted there's no
maximum of 200,000 I simply divided the
200,000 to make an appropriation of
100,000 in the first year for half a
year oh and then we'll we'll do it
whatever we want next time and it could
be more or less depending on how the
program gets implemented I see
okay are there are there any questions
rep
aable just following up on chair wier's
question is this enabling or it's
required per Court um I believe it's
it's enabling right is the way I read it
um there's going to be a program right
and then when and then this is like the
carrot right so if a county does it they
get the the $5,000 a case and it does
say the state that that courts May rece
rece an annual reimbursement per case
right it's an and you know the theory
behind this is it ends up saving people
money because like drug court they're
not in jail right so so they have they
do have fairly good incentive to do it
but the question was is it sort of again
for the smallest counties is it more
trouble than it's worth and that kind of
thing
so all right
so what would it be like to do with
1384 are there any more questions it's
being moved by representative Maguire
seconded
by represented
Griffin all right um we okay with just a
show of hands on this doesn't seem too
controversial all ready to show of hands
of supporting the
motion C
unanimous okay Mike something else get
to us for tomorrow and this amendment
number will change after I correct the
appropriation thank thank you we'll take
a short break and then we'll come back
and deal with
cannabis smoke break a smoke
[Laughter]
break yeah why don't you have one of
those breakes here
St
were you in the house when they had
smoking in the chamber yep in the anti
not in the chamber in the anti room
everywhere
e
so before we start on uh House Bill
1633 going to recess our work session on
House Bill
10005 House Bill
318 and Senate Bill
252 until 10:00 tomorrow morning where
we should have the final version of our
work this afternoon so yeah I actually
uh oh Senate Bill a bill in the Senate
perfect
right
yeah yeah it's just to make sure
yeah okay so now we'll open the work
session on
1633 and uh Mr Hoffman just handed out
an amendment with my name on it which is
combining several things that we did
last week and also uh representative
Leon's language that we discussed so Mr
Hoffman do you want
to go through your
markup yes um what this does is it takes
the two amendments number 1356 from
representative Leon and your Amendment
1339 h combines them into one and it
also um on the penalty for public
use changes the misdemeanor to class b
instead of a um undesignated
misdemeanor which could be an A and
could result in jail
time the uh appropriation sections um I
asked them to use uh the leash Amendment
which is a charge against the liquor
fund there's one difference there's a
position in a small appropriation in the
lay on Amendment mment that I have not
included in here
um
which might should have might have I
don't know but I just didn't know if the
committee was aware of the appropriation
and the additional position I can make
that change easily if you would like to
include
it any discussion on that including the
language for the additional support
person representative Grassi did I see
heading for the mic no what was the
position position was on a classified
position to the Department of Health
Human
Services um
to to complete the responsibilities
relative to collecting analyzing
reporting of
data it was
$109,000 for fisc year
2025 represent Maguire you have any
thoughts isn't there
already I'm thinking
$500,000 for collecting data or maybe it
was just a hundred for collecting data
something like that 100
yeah the good representative from Deary
yeah right
here um thank you Mr chairman um with my
amendments it moved the data collection
out of a department that does not do
that into Department of Health and Human
Services and they would need that
position in order to do the data
collection which captures Baseline so
that we can understand um from how
things look today and compare it with
the future um which is why there is that
position for the data there's the
$500,000 which is for the public
education campaign and that is actually
one that is um homeless if we remove the
substance use prevention and treatment
Recovery Fund however an education
campaign in order to have fact-based not
fear-based education about the risks of
cannabis is something that is very
crucial to the harm reduction effort um
through
legalization so that's something that um
the department could speak about how to
have the education campaign since we've
removed the substance use prevention
treatment and Recovery Fund um doing it
through that is a lot easier well it's a
little cleaner so that that money
doesn't get diverted to other use but
there may be flexible ways order to make
sure that we can start that public
education
campaign yes represent McGuire thank you
so um Mike on page 21 line
18 so is is this the 100,000 in addition
to the position of 10 and something
thousand or is it really the same
purpose
are you looking in the bill as amended
by the house the the amendment you just
handed out Lehman 1381 H page
21 line
18 $100,000 for Department of HHS for
the purpose of collecting Baseline data
so is that like that you said that they
we need we need a person there right so
is that just going to change the 100 to
105 or is it this is like I don't know
computer time that the person needs to
use or something you
know I'm gonna go back to the amendment
from last
week no that's not the same
appropriation
I don't think page 20 of course should
go into the data collection and what
it's all about what that needs to be
done
yeah the $100,000 didn't change what
what I did not include was the position
in the
$109,000 from the lay on
Amendment
Mike the other Mike would you like to
maybe you know a little more about this
because it looks like the $100,000 was
just for the cost of data collection
but thank you very much for the record
my name is Michael Holt I'm the
administrator of the theraputic cannabis
program with the Department of Health
and Human
Services
um
the bill is introduced had a $100,000
appropriation given to the Department of
Safety to do data collection on Baseline
data and health outcome data um before
and after
legalization uh testimony in house
Commerce uh indicated that they do not
have the capacity for that um and uh so
HHS volunteered to take on that work the
$100,000 um uh through our fiscal note
we've indicated that we need
$109,000 so that is is supposed to be
the uh the difference the 109 replaces
the 100 and also um the I believe
representative Lan's Amendment or a
version somewhere in these piles you
know includes an authorization for us to
create a new position um a data analyst
position so for clarity the 100,000
should be 109 and there should be
additional language to create um the the
data systems analysis analyst
position
thank you will this person be doing
polling or something is that how how
would the where would the data come
from so the language um the the
requirement that establishes the
language that
requires this work to be done requires
the department to enter into memorandums
of understanding with various agencies
uh that
house relevant data including Department
of Education um the commission
itself um Etc so the language is General
um and and it authorizes the department
to enter into with other agencies that
house that data to collect that data to
um report that data um out on a um fixed
schedule in the
law we do not have the capacity to do
this work with current staff we need an
additional position for this work to be
accomplished and the dollar amount for
that new position 9,000 9 that includes
benefits and yes
okay the pleasure of the division anyone
represent McGuire just said
sure okay and specifically for language
on my previous Amendment on the top of
page 19 um lines 1 through eight would
be the similar language in order to have
that position and the
$19,000 thank you you're welcome yeah
okay thank you
Michael are there any other questions
for representative
Le you have something else you'd like to
say uh yes and I apologize for keeping
coming back for more and more and more
and more but I have two Financial
related issues that I think would give
some clarification based upon the fiscal
note and some of the discussion of the
costs um it was discussed about the need
for enforcement before any rules were
created and before this Market was
created um it sounded like that may be
involved in looking at home grow or
anything else that could be seen as
competition to the market which would be
the premise for it um it seems to me
that it would be cleanest to leave any
enforcement of the controlled Drug Act
to those agencies that are already doing
that and by going to I I'll have to on
page seven line five in enforcement
Authority um if we would change that to
read the commission it already says the
commission shall have the primary
responsibility for enforcing this
chapter I would add the sentence
enforcement of chapter 318-b shall not
be included in the responsibilities of
the commission and then go to the local
and law enforcement cooperation that
would make it clear that they are not
expanding their scope into the larger
drug issues but they're simply involved
looking at the Commerce that is involved
um it seems like that would be a good
way to keep cost in
line and you have that language you can
give to Mr Hoffman I do I even have it
highlighted that I could hand out to
everybody along with my other um small
comment which is around operational
control let me hand
that and you can ignore the other Pages
there were quite a few places where
things could have been cleaned up
clarified moved to the FW without going
past what is tolerable um but I know
that you've been working on so many
details today um I think that we should
just keep focused on the most necessary
changes here um the other is um a large
part of why I separated out statutorily
the operational control from the
regulatory control was around the
concern of building out expensive
systems that would not be able to Pivot
should we not be able to implement the
agency model or the franchise model
should the other body move to franchise
um everything I'm talking about is just
on the the first page I there is more
that we could talk about if you had the
interest but this is most important um
so this would in the r making Authority
Under operational control um state that
um approve s submit statutory language
and approve rules subject to the
rulemaking process pursuant to RSA 541a
for the franchising cannabis re uh for
the agency cannabis retail outlets which
keeps all operational control distinct
from regulatory control the that's
pretty important because there aren't
any federal laws other than it's illegal
uh so if you're looking at having a
regulatory body regulate somebody that's
in a business operation with themselves
that gets to be a little complex the
Department of Health and Human Services
operates some facilities and their a
regulatory body so there is some
precedence to keep that clear and
separate it's good practice but it's
going to be a lot easier in the
rulemaking process to make sure that
operational control and Regulatory
control are separate if we were to
include that
line and that would be on page 16 line
24 I apologize for not giving you where
it would slide in to um the amendment
and that is what the most recent the the
updated
Amendment so page 16 line you said
24 line
so adding to the end of that sentence
cannabis retail outlets uh which keeps
all operational control distinct from
regulatory control to that R making
Authority
questions representative wer I know you
support cannabis
not any comments or
questions um we're trying to make it all
read I did I think you sent that to
me I'll sub I'll substitute hom grow for
this whole
bill Virginia has home grow already I'll
substitute a home grow for the whole
bill that was representative grass
SE that
week well there's there's still time
representative grassy I think
representative Maguire would help you
with that Amendment
perhaps uh
any questions comments okay with the
suggestions
Congressman
[Laughter]
okay okay so Mike would be a problem
getting that in for tomorrow you think
those it's not a
lot so while representative L's here I
had a question for her earlier it was
brought to my attention that uh there's
a large billboard in Manchester
advertising
cannabis uh in Massachusetts and she
assured me that somewhere within the
language here there was something that
would prohibit out ofate advertising I
saw stuff for neon son and stuff like
that but so there is I probably missed
it but yes that's in a section that was
not changed by the amendment so if we
were to have this drafted as a replace
all if OS has the time then you'd be
able to find that within the language um
but it had it prohibits the advertising
and it has fines so by having the fines
we'd be able to stop those out ofate
advertisements for cannabis billb
birds all
right the pleasure of the division are
you ready to Move Along representative
McGuire
right okay seeing no further questions
thanks all right it's HED that we can
move something out of here today so the
division has something to present
tomorrow on 16:33 any further
discussion y sure go ahead and represent
Grassi are we moving these two sections
that that representative Le just
presented to us into this bill there no
no argument there okay unless there's an
objection seeing seeing
none so then we're back to Amendment
any do we cover everything Mike all the
changes again that representative L
offered and we talked about last week
that I offered in a very small small
Amendment with with the exception of the
position that I did not include and this
yellow language it would we're all set
added to
this
okay all right anybody like to move this
along
or
you represent
Sweeney oh I'll move along Amendment
1381 H uh with the changes that have
been discussed I'll second that
all right we can just have a show of
hands and then we can vote on the bill
as amended by our actions just show of
hands come on
Ken my the yeah
okay all right thanks uh I think it was
8 to
one oh I'm sorry I I didn't okay three
six to three six to three
right all right we'll take a roll if
there's an the adoption of
1633 as amended all right got a
different book for
that are you ready to move that
representative
Maguire no I'm ready to vote no okay
okay April Fool's Day I'm filling in the
date
okay so who's moving okay anyone like to
move representative
grassie and represent of Sweeney thank
you okay when the clerk is ready if
please call the
role okay so we're voting on HB
1633 as amended
by
1381 With The Changes we've noted
representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin no representative
Sweeny yes representative Camrose no
chair Wier no clerk vots yes
representative walner
yes representative grassie yes chair
lean yes
okay
we can cus at
9:15 we can caucus at
9:30 so I just want before we
call it quits here I just like to thank
Mr
Hoffman and Melissa's not here but Mike
has been
unbelievable trying to keep us together
here if it wasn't for Mike and Melissa
we would probably still be a month
behind so thank you Michael and
Melissa all right well thank you all
we'll see you tomorrow at 10 so so maybe
full committee CAU is at
10:30 yeah I don't think we'll be long
really we'll be done
thanks thanks
Ken
e
for